today we are testing out the new iphone
raw photos
but we're also testing out something
else the new mustang mock e it's all
electric
and this thing is incredible
so the latest version of the ios update
you're now able to take apple pro raw
photos they talked about this in the
keynote and now it's officially here
once you turn on the raw shooting in the
camera settings there's actually a
little raw button that will appear
in the interface on the camera app so
you can choose to either turn it on or
off
so i'm going to take some raw photos and
some regular photos and then we get home
i'll show you the differences between
editing both of those
so let's take some pictures of this
sweet freaking car man
let's do it dude god this color like
everything about it so this is how you
can determine if this is a first
edition and we've had so many people try
to like
basically run me off the road putting
their windows down trying to talk to me
about this car i'm like excuse me i'm
driving this is not
safe behavior i know it's cool and it's
not out yet
[Music]
excuse me sir tyler would you like a
ride
[Music]
okay bye
[Music]
you know what else is really cool
there's an app and i basically start the
car
with the app i can do all sorts of
controls on here
you can unlock you can lock you can
start the car you also have all kinds of
various controls
what happens if we click panic should i
click it should i click i should click
it i'm in a panic right now tyler
oh shoot oh my god how do i stop it
okay i'm gonna press a button on my
phone
and i'm gonna open the trunk this is
revolutionary technology
yeah you want to watch me close it now
yep it's the future
the front-facing camera can also shoot
raw images so let's test that out
against this beautiful blue background
[Music]
the interior is so amazing it has this
huge screen
and the seats are actually made of a
vegan leather and it's really
really soft and comfortable there's also
heated seats and the steering wheel is
also heated i know i live in los angeles
and that's probably not needed
it's been pretty chilly lately and my
bum has been nice and toasty
now do you want to watch me drive really
fast
legally in all of the as fastest as i
can possibly go in the speed limit
[Music]
let's go
we have an insta360 one 1x2
on the roof look at that look at this
sunroof
man this car is nice we've made so many
friends
i met a few tesla owners who said if
this
had a better charging infrastructure
that they would buy this over the tesla
i'm just saying i'm just saying we need
to work on the infrastructure for
charging
wow okay the steering wheel is it's
heated right now
it's so warm on my little thingies is
this a camera review video we're not
sure what this video
is i want to fly oh my god
do you hear that sound that's not real
there's an option on here that you can
set to have like an audio
feedback so that you know when you're
you know
hitting the pedal
i freaking love this car right now i
have it on so there's a
one pedal drive i'm only driving with
one pedal so when i
take my foot off the gas it starts
slowing down
does he want to race me excuse me hello
don't you get car sick yep oh no
oh god my heart just drops
[Music]
wow this is so pretty
oh man look at this
raw no raw
trying to cut out all the people
we pulled off to the side of the road so
quickly i'm still a little jarred
[Music]
oh my gosh it's so pretty
[Music]
i don't want to go back to the car but i
do because i love the car and i'm
cold and it's warm in there and fast
okay
[Music]
back from our photo walk photo adventure
car review
unsure of what we really did but we did
a lot of stuff because we have
a lot of pictures to go through and this
is really cool just kind of bringing
these all into lightroom
and kind of seeing the raw images next
to the not
raw images you have so much more
information to work with
you can adjust the highlights the color
and i really want to show you guys this
for anybody who's never done this type
of editing before on a raw image
here's all the images that i brought in
so let's pop into one of these
this is the raw image and this is our
non-raw image
you can tell that it's it looks very
different so this raw image is very flat
which allows you to basically edit this
however you want
so i'm going to go in
you're gonna be so hyped so here's my
edited version
here's the original edited original
this looks really good i'm gonna copy
and paste all of the edits that i made
under this raw image onto this non-raw
image
and you'll see that this photo basically
just falls apart here we go
copy paste it just looks
very over processed yeah i mean it's not
good
the blue color looks disgusting yeah the
yellow the yellow looks disgusting
the saturation the colors are totally
flat and look like they're
colored with like a marker it's gross
so i'm gonna copy and paste that setting
to another raw image
here yeah that's awesome wow this looks
really good
oh man i'm excited so this is a
front-facing raw photo
let's do a quick little edit
that's nice oh look at this
oh this is the jumping shot this looks
so
cool this is the raw image let's bring
up those
whoa that brought up so much of the
shadows
this is going to be a cool demo because
because it's going to be cool you'll see
[Music]
it's pretty it's pretty cool this m1
macbook
pretty impressed original
and an edit original edit
now let's copy and paste this onto this
image that is not raw
and it looks like the trash can
just spilled onto my macbook
[Music]
disgust this is gonna be a cool shot to
edit as well so you can see over here
this is apple embedded color profile if
you can't tell by looking at these
images which one is raw that's a good
way to be able to tell
wow look at this what
like i just like getting your reaction
look at this
and then facing it onto the non-raw
it's so bad i like it they make it so
easy to turn the raw images off and on
when you're in the camera app because
the file size is
much larger comparing one of these
images
the raw image is 26 megabytes compared
to
two megabytes that's a significant
amount of space that you'll be
using up to take raw images so i think
it's something that you might not want
to keep on all the time but for special
occasions like when you have an electric
car
that is not out for months god i miss it
already
i really love that mustang the cool
thing is when the iphone takes a picture
like this is still a perfectly
incredible photo like it just
automatically makes the picture look
really great but if you want to be the
one that goes in
and makes all those edits yourself
you can now do that thank you guys for
watching i would love to know have you
tried this out yet if you don't have
this
on your phone right now you might need
to do an update not only will we be
getting access to the apple pro raw
but the apple fitness app will also have
an update so you'll be able to
do the fitness plus classes if you have
an apple watch i look forward to hearing
what you guys think about this
this is so amazing and i cannot wait to
take some more raw images
i wish that i could go to hawaii to test
it out
[Music]
you